- Internet trolls.
They're coarsening our discourse
and dividing our nation.
Is there anything
we can do about it?
Let's turn, again, to our panel.
Joining Grant and Nora
is Grammy nominated
folk flutist, Peter Thrush.
(jazzy flute music)
That ruled.
Peter, did you write
that or improvise it?
- Improvised.
- Nice.
- Artists are, often,
unfairly targeted
by the troll community.
As a musician, how would you
deal with a troll assault?
- Well, Ted, after getting
over the initial shock
of finding out trolls
are real creatures,
I'd look for a
weapon to fight them.
Like, a spear.
- No, no, no, no.
Sorry, we're talking
about internet trolls.
Which are people
who say mean things
online because they
hate themselves.
- Sorry, I misunderstood.
- Yeah, I think you did.
But, you know, you raise
an interesting point.
What if these trolls
were actual trolls?
Nora, your thoughts?
- Look, Ted.
If only 10% of America's
bridges have trolls,
that's still a staggering
number of trolls.
- It is.
That's a terrifying
statistic, if true.
Grant, trolls, talk.
- I would conjecture that we
are not prepared for this.
They can emerge at
anytime, attack.
Axes glinting in the moonlight.
- Well, no.
I would argue that out
military is equipped to handle
a troll raiding party.
- Yes, but you're not
taking into account
their, possibly,
bulletproof skin.
- Please, let me finish.
I was about to
suggest that trolls
likely carry unknown bacteria.
Look, millions dying
of root plague.
Probably wish they had
their skulls crushed in
by the first wave of
iron battle boots.
- But, how would they know
that now is the best time
to strike while our
president is stuck in a hole?
- Because maybe the trolls
got to the president first.